Do you do genetic testing reviews for a family member?
If so, do you give recommendations and attrition on what they should take?
That brings us back to this slide that our new courses.
So what of our new courses that were offered that won't be live for probably two weeks is a course on genetics.
So it's going to go everything genetics in that course.
And in that course, that's where people can just purchase that course and get a genetic review done.
But if you're a family member, then just call and ask to talk to Angie.
She can get your all set up for that.
So we used to not do genetic reviews for people that are not family members of patients.
Now that we're going to have this course going, that enables us to do genetic reviews on anyone.
So because people will be watching the videos and learning from that, not doing as many one of the ones calls and have a genetic review.
By monthly zoom call where they can ask questions that will be within.
So the answer is yes, family members can do genetic reviews.
And yes, they will get recommendations for nutrition and diet.
So contact the clinic and ask for Angie to get that set up.
The genetic kit set out set out for your family.